[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD GREEN: Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Brad Green.
I'm a director here at Google,
and I'm in charge of the
AngularJS project.
Today we're going to be talking
about the MEAN stack.
This is a little bit different
than things I
usually talk about.
Angular is a client-side
templating framework.
But it's not a full picture.
It's only the part that runs
inside the browser.
Today we're going to talk about
the other pieces that
you might select as
the backend--
the server pieces for
your application.
Today I'm joined by Val Karpov
from MongoDB, Ward Bell from
IdeaBlade--
who's going to be talking
BreezeJS--
and then Al Tsang
from StrongLoop.
And we're going to start off
with Val, who coined the term
the "MEAN" stack, and MEAN
standing for Mongo, Express,
AngularJS, and Node.
And Val, would you take us
through a little bit about the
history of how you came to pick
the stack and why you
thought it was a great idea?
VALERI KARPOV: Absolutely.
Thanks, Brad.
Let me just pull up my slide.
Cool.
So hi, guys.
My name is Valeri Karpov.
I'm currently a Kernel Tools
engineer at MongoDB.
And I am the one who originally
coined the MEAN
stack in a blog post on
the official MongoDB
blog back in May.
Here are some links to some of
my other stuff if you're
interested in reading more
about the MEAN stack.
But let's get started.
So a little bit more about me,
just so you all don't think
I'm some random guy
on the internet--
little bit of my back story.
I was originally the CTO of
SCVNGR, now known as LevelUp.
I've been using AngularJS
for a very long time--
since 2010--
mostly because I follow Misko
Hevery who originally wrote
the library [INAUDIBLE] working
very closely because I
was an intern under
him in 2009.
I got started using the MEAN
stack when I was working on
the Ascot Project, which was
a fashion tech startup that
we'll be talking about
a little bit later.
And that startup has
since folded.
I'm currently working for
MongoDB on an internal
continuous integration
project.
So what are we going to
be talking about?
The talk will be about basically
why my team first
started using the MEAN stack for
Ascot Project and why we
ditched Ruby on Rails, why the
MEAN stack is great for
prototyping, and how the MEAN
stack makes automated testing
super easy.
So as Brad mentioned, the MEAN
stacks for MongoDB, ExpressJS,
AngularJS, and NodeJS.
A little bit more about each of
the individual components.
MongoDB is a document
database.
It's to bridge the gap between
a document store like Redis
and a database like your
standard mySQL.
We want to get you the
performance and ease of use of
a document store with
the rich feature
set of an SQL database.
So you can do things like build
indices, use a rich
query language, and
do aggregation.
But what you're storing is
essentially objects.
You're not trying to fit
things into columns.
You're just storing what is
semantically a J file.
ExpressJS is a light web
framework on top of NodeJS
that gives you a bunch of helper
methods to write out
routes and do MVC on the server
without obscuring the
things that make NodeJS
particularly awesome.
AngularJS--
you probably have heard
a lot about it.
I like to describe it as
basically a magical library
that makes everything
client-side super easy.
And NodeJS is an event-driven
IO framework for JavaScript
that runs on the server side.
Essentially letting
you write a very
concurrent server very easily.
So the origins about
the MEAN stack--
the team that I was working on
Ascot Project with was my team
from TigerLabs which is an
incubator program from 2012.
We're working on a project
called TonightLife.
Now, TonightLife was essentially
an events
aggregation framework that
basically showed you cool
events that were coming
up in your area hand
curated by our team.
We had an AngularJS client for
the web, and then we had our
iOS and Android clients
as well.
The Rails backend and the
combination of Angular, iOS,
and Android was not particularly
the best way of
doing this.
We had too many testing tools
and no way of sort of
integrating all of
them together.
So we had a little bit of unit
testing on the server.
We had some unit testing for
Android and iOS clients--
no real unit testing
for Angular.
So all these testing tools
ended up being a mess.
We couldn't test
the integration
between all these tools.
We also had a lot of different
HTTP requests going on.
Every time somebody hit a
route, we would often be
hitting the Facebook API three,
four, five times.
And in order to get that to work
fast, we would have to
make these HTTP requests concur,
basically running at
the same time instead of
blocking the server
while they were out.
But when you start introducing
threads in Rails, or in any
other language, you introduce
extra complexity and you
introduce a lot of
room for bugs.
And we ended up running into
a lot of odd-race missions.
And finally, debugging database
interactions was a
bit of a pain.
We were using ActiveRecord,
which is an ORM--
Object Relational Model--
that took the objects that we
were working with on the
server side and converted them
into a bunch of SQL feeds.
Now, the ORM did its own magic,
so we were not able to
see objects on the client side,
and we couldn't really
see how they would look to the
server and how they would look
in the database after the
ORM was done with it.
And all of this added up to
us having about 2 and 1/2
developers and five different
languages--
SQL, Ruby, Objective-C, Android,
and JavaScript--
that we had sort of juggle
in order to get
our product to work.
So when we decided to fold
TonightLife, we decided that
we needed something different
for our next project.
And that's where the Ascot
Project came in.
We decided that, for the
purposes of building out a
clean, simple product that would
work always, we wanted
to basically build it in one
day and go to AngelHack in
Washington, DC, in
November 2012.
For that, we settled on the
MEAN stack minus Angular.
Part of the reasons behind that
is, one, we wanted to
have a very simple data model.
So Ascot Project's business was
essentially being able to
tag product information
in images.
You would have this overlay that
would show you where this
product was the picture and
where you could buy it.
And then we convert a
billion [INAUDIBLE]
from the [INAUDIBLE].
Now, with MongoDB, we could
easily store this all at one
collection as opposed to having
separate tables for
tags and for products and for
images, which made our lives a
lot easier.
Also, we could do
parallelization much more
effectively with NodeJS simply
because NodeJS is
event-driven.
It's all through callbacks.
So we didn't have to
write any threads.
And on the backend, every time
you saved an image, what we
would do is we would basically
ping out an HTTP request to
several different affiliate link
providers and sort of get
ourselves the best affiliate
link for the particular
[INAUDIBLE].
Originally, we decided to go
without AngularJS because we
had some trouble with it
previously when we were
working on version 0.9.19--
was the one that we were
using for TonightLife.
So we wrote the tagger in
jQuery, and that turned out to
be a terrible, terrible,
terrible idea.
We had about 800 lines of
spaghetti code in jQuery that
we would never be able
to maintain.
So we rewrote in Angular.
It ended up being about
only 80 lines of code.
And we had 100% test
coverage--
or unit test coverage-- on it,
which was absolutely perfect.
So the philosophy of the MEAN
stack and what we believe that
this stack should be able
to help you do.
Ideally, any web stack should
help you prototype--
be able to build your product as
fast as possible and get it
out there into the hands
of your users.
Should be able to test it
automatically so that you
never push legitimately broken
code through-- product will
probably always work
as advertised.
And adapt--
you want to be able to change
quickly, iterate on feedback,
and make your product awesome
for your users.
And then you want the scale.
You want to make sure that you
can both add more machines to
your server deployment easily
and be able to utilize the
resources that you
have as well.
Now what we're going to talk
about in this talk is only the
first two steps.
Because the other two steps will
require a separate talk
all in themselves.
But we're going to talk about
how you can build--
what the MEAN stack gives you
to enable you to build a
usable product very,
very fast.
And then how you can also test
that product so your users
never see your code break.
I will sum this up as, build
fast and don't break things--
sort of the opposite of the
Facebook philosophy of build
fast and break things.
Works well for Facebook because
they have a lot of
users, and everybody uses them,
despite the face that
their code is broken
quite often.
As a small startup, I don't
believe that you can afford--
or as a small new app that
you're trying to get people
within your workplace to use.
You don't want to ship broken
code because you're losing
your users' faith
in your product.
And every time something breaks
when it shouldn't, that
just means people are
less likely to
be using your product.
So let's talk about what enables
you to build fast with
the MEAN stack.
one, it's super easy to set up
on Windows OSX and Linux.
You can check out subguide
on my blog.
All you need to do is install
NodeJS and MongoDB.
And again, I will put this up
SlideShare after this talk, so
don't worry too much about
having to click that link
immediately.
But one of the problems that we
had with Rails is, I don't
know if you guys ever managed
to successfully set up Rails
on Ubuntu, but I spent several
hours one afternoon last
summer doing that.
And I still could never
get it to work.
So thankfully, I
punted on that.
And now I get work done on my
Windows 8 machine, on my
MacBook, and on my multiple
Linux servers.
It works as advertised
on all of them.
The other big advantage of the
MEAN stack is, Since you're
writing the same language,
you're storing the same
objects on all levels.
Now, the dream with NodeJS was
the ability to basically write
your server in the
same language as
you write your clients.
MongoDB adds and sort of
completes that promise.
And it enables you to store
what are semantically JSON
objects into your database and
then query using JSON as well.
So here's a simple example
of how this looks.
This is the MEAN stack
to do repo on GitHub.
I will post a link that
in a later slide.
The UI essentially allows you
to create a task or to-do
similar to what you would
in your Gmail.
So we're going to say I want to
finish my MEAN stack talk,
and it's due on October
3, which is today.
And so Angular--
if you're not entirely
familiar with
how AngularJS works--
the one feature that basically
makes it as magical as it is
is called two-way data bind.
Two-way data binding gives you
the ability to declare an HTML
element and would then attribute
to the HTML element.
Say that the contents of this
particular element should be
tied to this particular
JavaScript variable.
So when the JavaScript variable
changes, the contents
of the HTML element change.
And when the contents of the
HTML element change, like this
text area that you see on your
screen, the JavaScript
variable will change to reflect
the new value as
entered by the user.
So here I just typed in, "Finish
MEAN stack talk,"
clicked on October 3, and my
JSON object has changed to
reflect this particular
state of affairs.
So I have a new to-do-- finish
MEAN stack talk, October 3.
And this dynamic template will
be passed, as is, down to the
database, as we'll see
in the next slide.
So this is some output
from NodeJS.
I've started my Node app
I'm going to get
from the command line.
And when I click be the Add
button in the previous view, I
do a post to todo.json, and
this is the output.
This is some logging output that
shows you the JSON object
that I get on the server side.
And as you can see, the server
has pretty much the same view
of the object as
the client did.
Basically this JSON--
the same yields with the
addition of an underscore ID
field for the convenience of
MongoDB in order to be able to
index on that.
And then, when we save over to
MongoDB, we can pull up the
MongoDB shell, which is actually
legitimately--
you interface with the shell
using JavaScript.
And MongoDB stores what is
technically a superset of
JSON, but when you're dealing
with JavaScript,
it is exactly JSON.
So the MongoDB shell will show
us the exact same object as we
saw on the client with the
addition of an ID and a
double-underscore V, which is
a version number that the
NodeJS layer occasionally
adds.
With MongoDB's dynamic schema,
basically with MongoDB, you
can store anything into
any table or any
collection that you want.
MongoDB calls it--
the equivalent of an SQL
table as a corruption.
There's no need for rake.
All you would need to do to be
able to insert a different
type of object is,
well, nothing.
You could wipe your collection
and then start putting in new
types of objects.
But you don't necessarily
have to.
So what is the advantage
of this?
Unless you're doing server-side
validation, you
only need to change your HTML
to store different data, or
different data types,
in your database.
So if you're going to build
something very fast, and you
don't necessarily care about
doing things like making sure
that the data being inserted
is correct because the only
people that are going to use
data are you and your handful
of selected testers, you don't
necessarily want to waste the
time trying to say, OK, let me
say this column is going to be
a 32-bit integer.
No, it's just a waste.
I want to be able to say, OK,
input type equals number.
Let me add another input
type equals number.
That represents a
different field.
And all of that is going to
passed the server and to the
database as is.
This makes it very, very easy to
write a usable product very
fast and then add service-line
validation and sanity checks
and correctness checks later.
It's also easy to debug because
your database is going
to look exactly the same as
what your client sees.
So you don't have to worry about
mentally translating,
OK, this is how my object
looks in JSON.
This is how it's going to look
in the database in all of
these different columns.
It's going to also lower
the barrier to entry to
understanding your code base
because you're only writing
JavaScript and storing JSON.
You're not going to be writing
SQL queries, writing Ruby on
the server, and then writing
JavaScript from it.
There's a little bit of
a limitation to this.
If you have multiple clients or
don't necessarily serve up
your JavaScript with each page
load, you might have some
difficulties with changing
the underlying routes.
But that's a problem for
after prototyping.
And don't break things--
automated testing makes
life super easy.
And when you only write
JavaScript, you only need a
couple of testing frameworks.
And all of your integration
tests come for free with
angular-scenario.
So Karma--
if you haven't heard of Karma,
it is a phenomenal, phenomenal
test runner that allows you to
basically launch a bunch of
browsers and run all of your
client-side, server-side, and
angular-scenario end-to-end
tests automatically
each time you save.
This makes it very, very easy to
basically just change code
very quickly and make sure
that you haven't broken
anything that is of any
significant importance.
Again, angular-scenario does a
great job of sort of give you
a smoke test of, have I broken
any particular page or flow
that the user depends on.
Nowadays the gold standard of
automated testing is called
continuous integration.
It works in different ways
in different places.
Google has been using continuous
integration, if I
recall, since 2006 or
2007 internally.
However, the way that we like
to do it at MongoDB is for
each commit, you run
a huge suite of
tests on each git commit.
And Karma allows you to
integrate easily with some
existing open source continuous
integration suites
such as Jenkins, Semaphore,
and Travis.
You can find more information
about that off of the
karma-runner.github.io.
So, all in all, this gives the
MEAN stack the advantage that
we can basically build our
code fast, add things as
necessary, and then being able
to automatically test from the
very beginning.
Basically getting the gold
standard of automated
testing-- continuous
integration--
for free right from the start
instead of having
to bake it in later.
So that's all I have.
Thank you guys very much
for listening.
I look forward to hearing the
rest of the guys from
IdeaBlade and StrongLoop
talking now.
So thanks for listening again.
Have a good one.
BRAD GREEN: Val, thanks a lot.
So I'll remind folks who are out
in the audience, we will
probably have some time for
questions at the end.
And there's a link at the top of
the YouTube live page that
you can click on and type a
question or vote on questions
that you see there.
So we're going to move now to
Ward Bell from IdeaBlade to
talk about BreezeJS and its role
in simplifying managing
the data streams that come
from the backend.
WARD BELL: Well that's--
hi.
I'm Ward.
I'm going to flip over
to my screen here.
And I trust that you
are now seeing--
yes, you are.
You are now seeing my screen.
So I'm here to talk about the
MEAN stack as well when it
intersects Breeze.
Hi I'm Ward Bell.
There's my Twitter handle,
and there's my
Breeze Twitter handle.
And I am a founder
of IdeaBlade.
We are a company that helps
people build business
applications--
forms-over-data applications,
mostly.
And we do it with infrastructure
products and
also professional services.
We help train, mentor, and,
in many cases, build the
applications for our clients.
And these days--
did I have that?
Yeah, I'd say that about--
let me back up.
The kinds of applications we're
talking about here with
respect to Angular are single
page applications.
Applications that are written in
HTML and CSS and JavaScript
and are executing predominantly
on the client.
And, in our practice, we're
seeing about 50% of our
current engagements are
building this kind of
application.
You don't want to start from
absolute scratch, so we're
recommending, for a presentation
framework, most
the time, we're recommending
Angular.
That's what people want.
That's where the momentum is,
and we go where they go.
We actually think it's great,
so how nice is that?
And then, for data management,
we're recommending a product
that we've written-- it's open
source-- called Breeze--
BreezeJS.
So here's what I want
to talk about.
I want to talk about why you
might be interested in Breeze
for your Angular application
development.
I'd like to show you how
Breeze works in action.
And then I'd like to show you
Breeze as it relates to the--
Just a minute, folks.
Let's see.
Ward, can we hear you again?
How about that?
Can you hear me now?
BRAD GREEN: Yes, we can.
WARD BELL: OK.
We seem to have lost the screen
share, so let me try
that again.
You are now seeing it.
OK.
I'll pick it up.
BRAD GREEN: Great.
WARD BELL: So I was saying
that Angular is a
presentation framework.
And just a second.
What I mean by that is that it
helps present information to
users and then respond
to their input.
It's a framework to
help you do that.
It's a library to help
you do that.
And that means that you're
focusing on putting
information on the glass, moving
from screen to screen,
binding data to the DOM.
Those are its primary
capabilities.
It has some other supporting
ones, but that's really what
it's about.
And we often talk about the
patterns that are in use--
MVC, MVVM, MV-whatever--
its Model View Controller,
Model View View Model.
But where's the M?
Where's the M-- the model?
And I think, for many people
first approaching their single
page apps, they say, well, you
know, I'll just make a bunch
of Ajax calls, and I'll
bind the results.
And if I that's what I want to
do, I can reach into the
Angular bag and pull out $http,
or I can pull out
$resource if the backend is
written in a REST-y style.
But I want to suggest to you
that this view is incomplete.
Because, business apps anyway,
it's not really a matter of
making an Ajax call and then
grabbing the data and throwing
the data onto the screen.
And I want to put some pressure
on you on this
thought that $http is just a
way to access JSON data.
Now you could come back to me
and say, well, you know, do I
really need any more?
I know I'm going to have
to write some code, but
seriously, what do I
need a library for?
So I want to ask you some
questions about your
application.
I want to ask you--
I'm going to ask you a series
of questions about your
application.
And I'm not going to give you
a chance to answer, but I'm
going to give you a chance
to think about.
So my first thought is, is your
model all one type or
does it involve multiple
types?
I mean, how many times do you
do a Todo application?
I don't write Todo applications,
and businesses
generally don't.
Instead, they tend to write
applications that have
multiple entities.
And these entities--
are they interrelated?
Well, let's take a look at
a really classic one.
You've got customers and orders
and line items and all
that other stuff.
And you expect to be
able to move from
one of those to another.
So when you think about this
complex object graph, how
often do you retrieve that?
How do you retrieve it?
Do you retrieve the whole graph
at once, or do you read
parts of it?
When do you retrieve it?
My impression is that people
don't grab the whole database
and load it at all at once.
So how do you maneuver
around in this?
How do you get from a customer
to an order, from an order to
a line item, over time,
on the client side?
Ask yourself of this data, are
any of the data really, truly
stable during the life
of the session?
Shippers and products
and suppliers
aren't going to change.
Customers, orders, and
line items do.
So should you pre-fetch and
cache these stable items in
order to make your application
perform well?
How are you going to
populate picklists?
How are you going to relate
those picklists to the
customers and orders and line
items that reach to them?
Do you have multiple views
of the same object?
Angular is all about creating
multiple views.
So, for example, if I had two
applications here, I might
have the speaker on one screen
and speaker on another.
Or I might have an editing
screen as well
as a display screen.
Same object.
How do I maintain that object
across screens without making
extra trips to the server?
Do you save all the changes
immediately?
A lot of demos I see, you change
the name and boom, it
gets saved.
That's not the way most business
applications work.
You often have workflows,
and you're accumulating
information before the user's
ready to commit it.
They accumulate changes
during workflows.
So how do you know which
entities are dirty?
How do you know which ones are
going to save when the time
comes to save them?
You can't save everything.
It's also the case that, during
a workflow, you'll have
some inserts, updates
and, deletes.
If you're modifying an order,
you'll probably add some line
items, remove some line items.
You need to do that in
a single transaction.
How do you think
transactionally?
How do you prepare
a transaction
from the client side?
Can the user cancel the changes
when they suddenly
decide that they didn't
want to make those
changes after all?
How do they roll back
to a previous state?
Do you have to make another
trip to the server?
Another question-- do you
validate changes on the client
for a better user experience?
I mean, I realize you have to
validate on the server in
order to make the data integrity
right, but don't you
want to tell the user right
away, before they try and save
it, that there's a problem and
help guide them to a solution?
Do you think of these validation
rules as part of
your business model logic?
I mean, is it true, no matter
what view it is on there, that
that email address
has to be proper?
Well, if they are part of the
business rules, why would you
go around putting business rules
that belong in the model
into your HTML?
Why would go in there in HTML5
and add attributes there?
And how are you going to get
a desire to do that?
And how are you going
to maintain it?
Shouldn't the model
drive that UI?
Shouldn't the model validation
drive what appears on the UI
when there's a validation
violation?
What if the user closes
the browser in the
middle of the work?
Happens all the time.
I go up there, click
something, oops.
Users do that.
What if they had unsaved work?
How would you preserve
it and restore it?
If this is a business
application, not just some
consumer site, they're not
going to be very happy.
They're not going to be very
productive unless you have
some mechanism for doing that.
So I don't think you can find
answers to these questions
just in making Ajax calls
with http or $resource.
But I think you can find
these answers when
you're using Breeze.
And of course you could write
it all yourself--
thousands of lines--
or you might consider using a
library to help you just as
you say to yourself, well, I
could write it all in jQuery,
but I think I'd rather
use Angular.
Let's take a look at an
application briefly that just
does some of the things that
I'm talking about.
It's an application that is--
it's a sample from John Papa.
And it's about come out on his
Pluralsight course on Angular
and Breeze.
And here is in action.
When I load it up--
I'll just start it up.
And there's a bunch of toasts
here telling you
diagnostically what's going on
as it loads at all from--
or loads various parts
of things and
certain things are happening.
I can go in.
And it's really about code camps
and sessions, and you've
all attended conferences
before.
So I can go and have a session,
and I'm going to
another screen.
Notice I'm pivoting around
something that was expressed
this way in one view.
And then I'm going here.
And by the way, I've cached this
data, so I'm restoring it
from cache.
So I don't have to make
another server trip.
If I whack this like this, I'm
getting a response back
telling me that there's
an error here.
Well, that's because I don't
know what the title is.
But, you know what?
Life doesn't stop when I don't
know what the title is.
So I should be able to
go away and continue
working on other things.
Well, but if I go back
in, I want to know
exactly where I was.
That's because I'm keeping a
work in progress, which will
help me navigate back
to the ones that I
was working on before.
And that work in progress
could, as it is in this
example, be stored in local
storage, so that, were I to
close this, and I'm
not going to.
Instead I will do is I will go
back to sessions, and I will
rerun the thing and say let's
pick up where I left off.
That's kind of the equivalent
of closing the browser.
There it is.
Aha.
I'm working on it.
And now I'm working
on that session.
So you see just some of the
kinds of things that I was
talking about in there.
Let me go back.
So the thing I just showed you,
which is a code camp or
sample, and will be available
on Pluralsight--
great course--
is an Angular app, but it's
backed by a SQL database.
I want to show you, because
we're talking about the MEAN
stack and Mongo and Node and
Express, I want to show you
another application--
also an Angular application--
that is written to
talk to Mongo.
And let me find that.
That's right up here.
Wrong one.
You can actually get the sample
I'm about to show you
from our Breeze sample site.
And here it is.
Here is Zza, our pizza place.
And we can go and
order a pizza.
Maybe I want to make my own.
I'll pick a price for it,
and maybe I want to pick
my sauce and meat.
And I know I want to have some
salad with it, so I'll come
over here, and I've got that.
And maybe I'll go back, and
I'll add it to my cart.
And I can look at my cart.
OK.
So this has that kind of
Angular, move around on the
screen kind of thing, navigate
back and forth, keep track of
your stuff, do validations, make
selections, and all that
kind of thing
Looks just like--
it could as easily have been
written against a SQL database
in which you could imagine with
the underlying parts are.
And in fact, there is a version
of this application
that does run against
a SQL database.
But this one is running
against Mongo.
And I want to show you a little
bit about what the
implications of that are.
Hold a second while
I control--
that's where that is.
So if the data that you had just
seen there about-- that
were driving the
pizza parlor--
were represented in SQL, you
would see individual tables
for each of the items--
Orders, OrderItems,
OrderItemOptoins, OrderStatus.
But because this is Mongo that
we're talking to, in fact,
what I've got for an
order is not--
I don't have OrderItems
and OrderItemOptions.
I have a document.
Because Mongo is particularly
good at
representing things as documents.
Of course, not everything can
be in the same document, and
I'll show you that.
So some of the items are sort of
like drop-down lists, like
what the products are and what
the product sizes are.
And some of them are other kinds
of volatile objects,
like customers.
And they're all interrelated.
So you still have navigations
between elements of documents,
but you also have this notion
of a document representation
instead of a table
orientation.
And we can play a little
bit with that.
Here's a view over the order.
And you'll notice that--
I just happened to be looking at
one of them in particular.
And I can-- oh, by the way, you
don't have to deal with
primitive type, so here's an
address with a [INAUDIBLE]
type--
with what we call a complex
type-- an embedded type.
And you have OrderItems.
So here is a pizza,
and it has options
like barbecued chicken.
So you see it's really
a document.
This is no way representable as
a row within a data table.
Now one of the things that
I think is particularly
interesting about this
sample is that the
front end is the same.
It's still the same Angular.
It's still the same Breeze.
But all we've done, with a few
minor adjustments, is switch
back to being able to
tweak the backend--
give you a backend--
that's running in Node and
Express with Mongo.
And we're able to twist the
model so that it can deal in
Breeze with documents, not just
with table structures.
And just a quick look.
Usually the server side is
fairly simple, as you were
hearing earlier.
It's pretty easy to get going
in this MEAN stack.
So I have a simple HTML, but
this is the-- all you have to
do on the Express server--
this kind of web server--
and you just figure out what
things you want to use, and
you figure out what your routes
are, and you route
those things to--
well, we have some Breeze
components for Node
that make it easier.
And you're off and running.
As I said, this sample is
available to you from our
samples page.
So that is kind of an overview
in which I'm trying to
encourage you to think about
data as a more significant
problem than simply
going for Ajax.
That you can combine
Angular and Breeze.
That you can have a SQL backend,
or a Mongo backend--
Breeze is agnostic with
respect to that.
And so you can have it the
way you want it-- maybe
prototype it in one.
Or maybe you have a hybrid
application, which has a mix
of a Mongo database, a
document-oriented database,
and a SQL database.
And you can unify those on the
client side with a Breeze app.
Thank you.
We'll probably get to the
resources later in the show,
but I'll just say it now that
there are some courses that
you could look at on Pluralsight
to learn about
Breeze, about the application
that I just showed you.
There's John Papa's course.
You can go online with us.
And just think that your rich
data, it really is a breeze.
Back to you, Brad.
BRAD GREEN: Ward,
thanks so much.
That was awesome.
I think Breeze is
very exciting.
So we're going to go over
to Al Tsang now.
Al is with StrongLoop.
He's going to talk about how
Mongo can work for the
enterprise in the
mobile space.
AL TSANG: Thanks, Brad.
Hi, everyone.
This is Al Tsang, CTO
of StrongLoop.
I'll go ahead and get started
by sharing my screen.
Here we go.
So brief presentation.
Thanks, everyone,
for having me.
We're going to go ahead and
talk about LoopBack.
Again, as Brad had mentioned,
LoopBack is a mobile backend
in which you can hook your
Angular application to.
We're focused on the
mobile space.
LoopBack is an Open
Source Mobile
Backend-as-a-Service, or mBaaS.
And it features BACN.
And I'll get to what
BACN's all about.
So real briefly, a little
bit about StrongLoop.
We were founded at the
end of 2012 by Bert
Belder and Ben Noordhuis.
They're two core maintainers
in NodeJS.
They've been there since the
beginning the project.
Along with myself and a
friend and colleague
of mine named Raymond--
We built the mobile backend
for shutterfly.com.
As a company, we develop and
support StrongLoop Suite.
It's our product offering
by subscription.
It contains three components--
so LoopBack-- the open source
mBaaS that we talked about.
LoopBack is built on top of
StrongNode, which is a
certified package of Node and
select certified community
modules that are commonly
used in the enterprise.
And we round out our offering
with StrongOps, which is a
real-time performance
monitoring
and operational dashboard.
This lets you not only visualize
what's going
on with your apps.
We intend on making it be
operational, so actually do
something with for apps--
scale it, triage it,
so on and so forth.
As a company, and as a good
citizen of open source, we
also contribute to Node and its
rich ecosystem within npm.
So we've done contributions
to node-inspector and
node-reggie, and we continually
comb over the Node
universe to figure out what's
there in the community that
could be leveraged in
the enterprise.
So let me start by outlining
sort of the problem of what
we're trying to solve
with LoopBack.
Mobile devices need
to get to data.
If you think about all the
applications running on your
smartphone, look at the ones
that actually do something
useful or are productive
within the enterprise.
They need data.
They don't need just data that
exists in the cloud that's new
or native to the mobile
application.
They need data that's there,
that's like your banking data.
So this poses a bunch
of challenges.
Number one, the data itself,
there's authentication,
authorization, and accounting
issues.
Oftentimes, the data's not
even in the right format.
Like it's in XML, where it's in
a bunch of rows of tables.
There's too much of that data.
Can you imagine if your mobile
device asked for the customer
master at a large B-to-C company
like one that we
worked for at Shutterfly.
You'd get back 6 million-plus
rows.
And then, on top of that,
there's multiple data sources.
Even if you had just one
database, you'd probably have
a bunch of instances
of that database.
And lastly, you wouldn't even
want all those devices to be
hitting your backends
directly.
So today, we're going to be
centering around our use case
and example around this mythical
military equipment
rental surplus vendor
called Blackpool.
And in this illustration, we
have this said warmonger, and
he's looking for an
Apache helicopter.
And he needs it by tomorrow
because he's
about to wage a war.
So from this mobile device, he
wants to look up, using a
geocode lookup on his device
getting his coordinates, a
list of rental locations that
might have inventory for
Apache helicopters against
Blackpool.
Once he actually finds something
from the mobile
device, he needs to actually
reserve it.
And upon reserving
it, he needs to
authenticate who he is.
Does he have a credit
limit, for example?
Getting his profile-- is
even authorized to do
something like this?
And finally, post payment,
which sets another set of
challenges and transactions.
So as you can see, this is not
very efficient doing all from
the mobile device.
You could, but you'd run
into a bunch of issues.
Our answer is to basically
develop mobile middleware
optimized for this use case and
leverage enterprise data
on the backend.
So this is our solution.
A Mobile Backend-as-a-Service,
or mBaaS, you can think of it
as an open source Parse you
control, if you're familiar
with the vendor Parse that
was acquired by Facebook.
So if you want to think about
it in terms of MEAN, think
about it as MEAN gone mobile.
LoopBack actually utilizes
ExpressJS.
So you can use
Express-compatible middleware
by using app.use with your
favorite middleware and extend
upon LoopBack.
We basically connect devices
to browsers--
connect devices and other
devices to the
enterprise data itself.
It's all written
in Node, proven
language for mobile backends.
We've seen this use case used
over and over again.
And it's open source, so
you can extend on it.
And A key differentiator for us
is that it's on premises or
in your cloud.
You decide where to
run LoopBack.
We have SDKs for iOS.
Android we're just polishing
up right now.
We're developing our
JavaScript SDK.
And we have BACN.
BACN is what relates us to our
front-end implementation, and
I'll talk more about
that in a second.
And then we have the rest of
StrongLoop's suite, which is
the bundling of the other
components that
round out our offering.
So operationally monitor your
stuff that's going on in
LoopBack as well as the core
fundamentals of Node that
powers the app.
Real briefly, then,
the architecture.
Again, we have Mongo.
We have all these
data sources.
What we've built is basically a
layer of abstraction called
the data source juggler.
From the data source juggler,
you get back a model--
something that you can actually
relate to as a mobile
[INAUDIBLE].
And as you build models and
define these models against
your data sources, we
[INAUDIBLE] a REST API.
We also have a gateway that
allows you to secure the API,
[INAUDIBLE] off to, mediate with
it to be able to change
from different content
payloads.
And it acts as a reverse
proxy to multiple
instances of API servers.
All of this data is stored
in a repository in JSON.
And we use basically the
underlyings of git and others
at the distribute source control
mechanism so that you
can unify multiple LoopBack
instances into
one single run time.
Now let's talk about BACN.
Why did we call it BACN?
Well, who doesn't like bacon?
BACN stands for Bootstrap,
Angular, Cordova, and Node.
What we're betting on here is
a front-end framework for
LoopBack to develop mobile
web apps or hybrid apps.
And we're looking forward to
partnering with the Google
Angular team to carve out the
niche for Angular formal
mobile web.
And now I'd like to jump
into a quick demo.
If you'd like to follow along,
or follow up with this demo,
you can go to our docs
page and go to
LoopBack Quick Start.
We have Quick Starts for all
three of our components.
And then you can continue on
with the BACN sample, which we
just released last
night on GitHub.
All right, so to get started,
the first thing you would want
to do is get to our
get started page.
If you register on our site and
go to our downloads page,
you can go ahead and pick which
platform that you'd like
to develop in.
Or, alternatively, we have this
neato Cloud9-based IDE,
in which you don't even have
to download anything.
You just start with LoopBack,
and the rest of StrongLoop's
going to be running
in the cloud.
From there, as I mentioned
before, go to our docs page.
And then, from the docs page,
go ahead and click LoopBack,
and we have this Quick Start.
So the first thing we want
to do is, again, install
StrongLoop Suite.
And then you're going to go
ahead and initialize the
StrongLoop Suite sample
application.
For the sake of time, I've
gone ahead and done that.
And I've installed it
already on my Mac.
So I'm going to go ahead and
run the application now.
And it starts up.
And in another browser--
just go ahead and close these.
So what you're seeing here is
the physical manifestation of
a RESTful API for Blackpool.
And we have these model entities
that are out there--
weapons.
So you can play with this
RESTful API all
through this page.
So getting a collection
of weapons, get a
weapon, buy an ID.
We offer is very similar
syntax to
what Mongo has, right?
Mongo query language has been
a fantastic example of being
able to get to sort of a
JSON-oriented query structure.
So, in this case,
I have weapons.
Give me the ones that are have
an effective range greater
than 900 hydrogen just give
me the first three.
You can continue to play
along with this API.
And again, as you build these
models and defined them
against their underlying data
sources, we build an API.
And what we've done is build
and API explorer.
So you can actually go ahead
and click on, for example,
locations and get a
list of locations.
Try it out.
Get back the same JSON output.
So that's the API explorer.
So from here, from the Quick
Start then, we jump into the
Getting Started Guide.
And the Getting Started Guide
basically allows you to
consume this RESTful API.
And we're going to go ahead
and do that now.
And instead of using our mobile
client that we have
natively for iOS, we're going
to go ahead and use BACN.
So what I [INAUDIBLE] ahead and
did to save time is clone
the BACN repo, and
I'm going to go
ahead and run the client.
So normally, I would do this in
the emulator on Android or
on iOS or whatnot, but I'm going
to go ahead and do this
in the browser because this is a
little bit hard to see here.
So let's go ahead and run the
same thing going on in Chrome.
And hopefully that's a lot
bigger and better to see here.
So this is our BACN app.
It's all in Angular.
In fact, let's take a
look at the code.
Really simple.
In the main, we have a bunch
of routes to define.
We've defined our resource group
which binds, by local
host, the RESTful API coming
from the sample app, to the
Angular SPA.
We have a bunch of controllers
that actually drive the logic.
And as I move on to the
tutorial, if I go to page one,
this is just text.
This is lesson one, and I'll get
to lesson one in a second.
We have a bunch of services that
we've defined as well, as
an Angular module.
So we've actually defined this
model called ammo and bound it
to the RESTful endpoint.
Same thing for weapons
and locations.
Really simple stuff.
OK so going back to
the application.
So, lesson one-- so to
illustrate the power of
LoopBack, what we've done is
we've basically developed
three lessons to show some
of the key highlights.
So lesson one is all about the
model and having a schema-less
definition of what that model
is on the database.
And what I mean by that is, if
I actually go to the models
directory and I look at ammo,
you can see that its
properties are null.
And in my Angular app, I've
gone in to find properties
that I'm going to go ahead and
put in-- so name, caliber, and
a Boolean on whether or not
it's armor piercing.
So let's go ahead and curl this
application's data store.
We're using the in-memory
database, which mirrors
exactly like Mongo except
it's not persistent.
And I get back null without
its carriage return,
conveniently.
So using the Angular app, and
then I'm going to go ahead and
hit the send request.
So super-duper ammo,
re-curl, and boom.
There you go.
Same thing--
rail gun 80 cals, absolutely
armor-piercing.
[BEEP]
AL TSANG: Whoops.
[BEEP-BEEP]
AL TSANG: Oh.
It's stuck on this.
There we go.
And there we go.
So again, a schema-less
model that's defined.
And you define its
model properties
on the Angular client.
So that's lesson one.
Lesson two, real quick now,
illustrates existing data.
So we've acknowledged at
LoopBack that enterprises have
existing data.
And that, although it's nice
to define new data for your
mobile apps, you want to
leverage your existing data.
So I'm going to go ahead and
re-run the application now.
And instead of connecting to
our memory adapter, we're
going to go ahead and
connect to a running
live instance of Oracle.
And just to give you a flavor
of what's going on here--
all right.
Table name, user tables--
and go ahead and describe
inventory--
actually product.
That's what we're going
to be showcasing here.
And I'm going to get back,
basically, the records that
are going against this
Oracle database.
So what's going on with this is
we're calling controller.
That's basically sending
requests.
And what's nice about Angular
is that it's very easy to
figure out what's going on with
these controllers and
what they're doing.
So in this case, I'm simply
hitting up weapons, which was
a linked through LoopBack to the
products table, querying
it, and getting back and binding
that to this view.
And again, through to the power
of, as Val put it, data
binding being bidirectional.
There's a whole slew of things
you can do here.
From a mobile application's
perspective, you have issues
like data sync, like save
eventually, save and forget.
But this gives us a rich
interface to be able to get to
meet the demands of what you
would normally build within
the native platform.
In the interest of time, I'm
going to stop there and
continue on with concluding
out LoopBack.
[BEEP]
So that's the demo.
If you would like to go ahead
and follow along, or follow
up, go ahead and go to
the Quick Starts.
We have Quick Starts, again,
for all three components.
A quick look at the roadmap.
So we just released this,
literally, two weeks ago.
And we're solidifying
our JavaScript SDK.
We just finished Android.
That's in testing right now.
As an mBaaS--
part of the reason why you
wouldn't want to adopt an
mBaaS is because
we've already--
we want to actually pre-build
mobile models for the most
common use cases.
So, like user for user
registration, file for storing
files and other [INAUDIBLE].
LBGeoPoint is our geopoint for
geonavigation and other
calculations on a
mobile device.
And of course, push
notification.
We're also working
on an editor.
Again, all in Angular.
That makes it even easier.
So you don't have to navigate
through code if you don't want
to, or use the CLI.
And mobile app management--
so how to actually develop your
apps that actually tie in
backends with your APIs.
And of course, more
connectors--
we have MySQL.
That's already done.
And we're looking to evaluate
enterprise systems.
So what's next?
Go ahead and please
try LoopBack and
register on our site.
We have their docs page
as I mentioned before.
We also have a community that
we've established, called
node-republic, that
we sponsor.
And if you have any questions,
please feel
free to contact me.
Here's my contact information
at the end here.
And that's pretty much it.
Back to you, Brad.
BRAD GREEN: Wonderful, Al.
Thanks so much.
I know I've already had
breakfast, but for some
reason, I'm hungry for bacon
here [INAUDIBLE].
I want to thank all
of our speakers--
Val, Ward, and Al-- for joining
us this morning.
And for everyone watching,
thanks for joining.
We'll see you on the web.
Please ask us questions.
Please try out these
technologies.
We're excited to see what
you guys build.
We'll see you later.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]